harvey catherine 1 samedi
les ouragans les plus dévastateurs de
l'histoire
tous sont survenus au cours des 20
dernières années
les ouragans avec les tremblements de
terre les éruptions volcaniques et
autres catastrophes climatiques dans le
monde ont engendré une facture qui
atteint 2900 milliards de dollars
américains pour la période entre 1998 et
2010 est pour les 20 années précédentes
ce montant était de 1300 milliards de
dollars la tendance est claire et le
pire serait à venir écrit increasing que
les température moyenne à la surface du
globe ont déjà augmenté d'un degré
celsius depuis le milieu du 19e siècle
rappelle-t-il
l'augmentation anticipée d'un degré et
demi aura donc de graves conséquences
pour l'humanité au canada la facture
totale des réclamations dépasse
régulièrement un milliard de dollars par
année depuis 2010 du jamais vu les feux
de forêt par exemple qui ont frisé le 3
milliards de dollars il ya deux ans donc
on voit ces épisodes là au québec on a
vu au printemps dernier l'épisode de
d'inondations que le gouvernement
estimait autour de 300 millions de
dollars les pertes les plus importantes
ont eu lieu aux états unis en chine et
au japon des pays avec des
infrastructures importantes
mais le rapport souligne les
conséquences disproportionnées des
désastres dans les pays pauvres où les
habitants sont cette fois plus
susceptibles d'être tué pour bip inpro
crise les personnes pauvres dans les
pays pauvres n'ont pas 20 ans 30 ans 40
ans devant eux
la plupart de ces enfants seront morts
averti cet universitaire qui a contribué
au rapport
déjà les catastrophes ont fait un
million trois cent mille morts dans le
monde depuis 20 ans et 4 milliards 400
millions de blessés de sinistrés ou de
déplacés il faut agir maintenant dit
l'onu c'était déjà une question de
survie
c'est aussi un enjeu économique ici
sébastien desrosiers radio-canada morère